what is something about Courtney's
performance from season one that you
wanted to hold tight to but then also
what is something you deliberately
wanted to do different to reflect how
the character's grown wow you come out
oh my goodness okay yeah she's tough
okay we're gonna go really fast and what
I wanted to hold him from Courtney's
performance was the Stillness she has
this beautiful nuanced Stillness to her
and those eyes I fall into them and so
coming into this I knew I had I had a
big role to play and so I took a little
bit of that
um and then the second part of the
question was something you deliberately
wanted to do different to show how she's
evolved great so what I did differently
was that we recreated Lottie that she's
come into the light or Charlotte and she
is a spiritual leader and she is a guru
in her own world so I got to them play
in the lightness and I think there's
there's nowhere to go if you start her
in the new season as being dark and you
know full of pain pain so I created this
beautiful love and light and Lottie and
uh that was so much fun so if you
created that beautiful love and light
does that mean she started that facility
like truly out of the goodness of her
her heart
I should feel it but you just never know
with this show no no she is pure she is
pure as the driven snow oh my goodness
um I have a question for both of you now
because they're especially like like
powerful and have very strong
foundations in the first season and now
in season two it feels like their
foundations are being rocked more than
any other character on the show so do
you have I guess like an anchor or a
Guiding Light that no matter what
headspace they're in or what they're
going through every choice they make is
always based in some sort of consistent
truth all along the way well absolutely
I mean when you're crafting a character
you have to
um craft who that character is their
history and all that sort of thing um in
television it changes from time to time
but the core of who taisa is
um she's a narcissist she's selfish even
falling apart in season two she's still
selfish
um you know I don't know how many you've
seen but her finding van you know that's
that's not to help van
that's to help herself and
um in in in trying to help herself uh I
think she reverts back you know it's
sort of like um your first love your you
when you're a teenager and you see that
person again you know uh 20 years later
you fall sort of right back into this
the old habits that you had and that's
the taisa you're gonna see in season two
she is nothing like season one taisa I
bet for Natalie and not only is a
totally different as well in that the
first season she was strong willed in
her ruin you're really seeing someone
Circle the Drain and do it in a harsh
manner
defiantly because her love uh has been
stolen from her
um and she's also just super toxic so
this new place she's cleaned up whether
it was not by choice but um I watched a
few things of people who survived
suicide that was really compelling
because you can switch on a dime to want
to live uh in that in a turn of events
um a guy who she does Ted Talks he
survived jumping off a bridge wow it was
really fascinating
um but different Natalie's wanting to
find the truth and she's softer and
um it's a really odd unfamiliar place
for her to be quite
um what you'd want for a person to to
fund by the end she wants answers for
everybody to do better